what I'm saying I think the only honest
thing now hi i'm lillian I'm Catalina so
I've been speaking French since I was a
kid I learned it in school so it's a
little rusty now because I've been
living in LA for three years I have not
used any of my French right but I think
I'll be okay too
I think I'll be able to handle it I have
been speaking Spanish according to my
mother since I was 7 months old it is my
mother tongue so I think I know it
pretty well
I actually took French in high school I
was really good at it back then but do I
really remember all of it
no really I I know how to say yo soy una
mujer are useful respect me just so you
don't have hit intimidated we're gonna
have fun we're gonna have fun yeah I'm
ready I can't come off no sorry like an
hour just taking my power blonde you
know in blonde
stupid no blonde oh yeah no fibers a
Tong a Sbarro's slippery uh-huh we
separate aha we're gonna pass almost
like a mummy man okay Stella bossy bossy
No thank we see [ __ ] fuels
come on Lee kept up the FAFSA now change
minute yeah nope
Josie go so grass we own it cleared out
Aussie pop much pasta fam lambasted
Abbas oh my god that Cuvier the most
caustic is perfecto
okay I think we didn't understand each
other fully but the languages are pretty
similar so pick up some more pick up
some words
jay-bez one died she come home so I base
one the the positive the plane died oh
wait wait
uh-huh but I okay all right I feel like
an expansion general like you talk
really fast so I have no idea
ordering in Spanish and especially me
it's like I don't have I don't use
separate words I use one G like these
you say honey cinema its Abdur Rahman
Allah knows it Ranade mm-hmm wait wait I
already knew that I sucked at Legos and
this is just like proof that I should
not touch Legos ever um is chaos the
wolf esto dreaming tsunade's know
Santino muy bien
don't disturb with to colleague over J
ceceo complicado a salmon Iran we cannot
have a point to the empties what if I
didn't know what I'm saying nothing or
only or nothing uh-huh I didn't know
that I sucked that Legos I just thought
that I've never really played with them
I'd have to be good Dalek difficile ego
swing me company America today - amiko
you know
okay I didn't think that it would be
this hard cuz you see kids putting
together and I'm like what does that say
about me
silver download the types of a new CD
okay oh my god I feel like we're just so
confused and trying to figure out this
that we at totally like blocked each
other out until we figure kinda
understood but we're like whatever now
with the final pieces so it's a Lego
that was a lot harder
although just met see the messy I'm
running one day you see ya it's over to
me son oh yeah hey on this right gets us
Accords since January I see that you
soon at Easter bienvenidos our non dress
Bienvenue a longer
I wanted to this challenge again but I
want to go home and practice on some
other Legos before I do and I'm gonna
come back at camp
nope I within five minutes I was like
already discouraged or like no I give up
so not touch this again do I have
different say Jose is it to modulus up
and they don't go past me Francis step
to the closet take it up and then give
my newest today up upon of Jose blue
blue the phosphate wait ah it's a map
from play Spaniard way that's care mujer
sip Sabathia where's my Forte's animal
[Music]